WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
INCONSISTENCIES.
YOU BROUGHT UP A POINT THAT SAYS
THEY'RE AGAINST BIG GOVERNMENT
UNTIL THEY'RE FOR IT.
IT ALMOST SEEMS LIKE THAT'S
EVERYBODY, AND I ALMOST THINK,
THEN, I WOULD BE OKAY WITH THAT
IF THEY MADE THIS INDIVIDUAL
CASES.
YOU KNOW, THIS RELIGIOUS LIBERTY
CASE IS AN INTERESTING ONE,
BECAUSE I REMEMBER BACK RIGHT
AFTER 9/11 THEY HAD WHAT WAS
CALLED THE GROUND ZERO MOSQUE.
EVERYBODY WAS AGAINST THAT.
YOU CAN'T BUILD THAT.
MAYBE A QUESTION OF RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO A GAY
COUPLE GETTING MARRIED AND
SOMEBODY WANTS TO BUY A CAKE
FROM A BAKER, WELL THAT'S
RELIGIOUS LIBERTY, EXACT SAME
PEOPLE STANDING UP FOR ONE
OR THE OTHER.
>> I THINK THE INCONSISTENCIES
AND LACK OF GENUINENESS ARE WHAT
BOTHER REPUBLICANS --
WHY CONGRESS HAS ABOUT A 10%
APPROVAL RATING.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> BUT I THINK YOU'RE EXACTLY
RIGHT, PEOPLE WHO LOOK AT THINGS
THE SAME WAY NO MATTER WHAT THE
ISSUE IS AND NOT WITH THEIR
PERSONAL BIAS INTO IT.
>> Jon: OR MAKE AN ARGUMENT,
YOU KNOW, THIS RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY ARGUMENT FEELS LIKE
THEY'RE WORKED BACKWARDS FROM
WE ARE AGAINST THE COURTS
GRANTING THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO MARRIAGE EQUALITY, AND
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
GET OUT OF THAT.
MAYBE WE'LL TRY THE STATES
RIGHTS ARGUMENT.
OKAY, THAT DIDN'T WORK.
NOW LET'S TRY RELIGIOUS LIBERTY.
>> BUT THERE IS ALSO SOMETHING
WE NEED TO SEPARATE OUT.
SO FOR EXAMPLE, THEY TOLD ME
THEY WERE GOING TO BUILD A
MOSQUE AT 9/11, I WAS HORRIFIED
AND THOUGHT IT WAS A TERRIBLE
THING, BUT AM NOT FOR A LAW TO
PREVENT THEM.
IF YOU WANT TO MARCH DOWN THE
STREET AND ARE PART OF THE
K.K.K., I AM HORRIFIED BYT
THAT AND OBJECT TO IT, BUT THERE
ARE CERTAIN-- THE FIRST
AMENDMENT IS ABOUT THE RIGHT TO
BE DESPICABLE.
IT'S EASY TO ACCEPT --
>> Jon: BUT YOU CAN'T HARDLY
EQUATE THE MOSQUE WITH THE
K.K.K. OR GAY MARRIAGE WITH THE
K.K.K. --
I HEAR THAT ARGUMENT A LOT.
>> THE THING IS I THINK YOU CAN
PERSONALLY OBJECT TO THINGS THE
LAW WILL ALLOW.
IT DOESN'T MEAN WE HAVE TO SAY
THAT WE ACCEPT EVERYONE ELSE'S
BELIEFS ON EVERYTHING ELSE.
SO FOR EXAMPLE, I'M ABSOLUTELY
FOR THE LAW ALLOWING -- NOT
PREVENTING A MOSQUE TO BE BUILT,
HOWEVER, AT THE SAME TIME, I
I THINK IT'S A REALLY REALLY BAD
IDEA TO BUILD A MOSQUE AT THE
9/11 SITE.
>> Jon: YOU DO KNOW THOUGH THAT
THERE WAS A MOSQUE THERE
ALREADY?
>> I KNOW.
>> Jon: I'M REALLY FASCINATED BY
THE IDEA OF RELIGIOUS
PERSECUTION IN THIS COUNTRY
BECAUSE THE DEPTH OF FEELING
SEEMS REAL.
>> FREEDOM DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
ALL HAVE TO AGREE WITH EVERYBODY
ELSE'S -- WHO THEY ARE, WHAT
THEY ARE, WHAT THE RELIGION IS.
WE DON'T HAVE TO LIKE EVERYBODY.
>> Jon: NOBODY'S ASKING YOU TO
BE HAPPY BAKING IT.
>> THE THING IS, WHERE I WOULD
SEPARATE IT IS PEOPLE WHO HAVE
PERSONAL OPINIONS, THEY'RE
AFRAID -- SOME PEOPLE ARE AFRAID
IN OUR COUNTRY THAT THEIR
PERSONAL RELIGIOUS OPINIONS
WILL NO LONGER BE ALLOWED EVEN
IN THEIR CHURCH. AND THERE ARE
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS,
OKAY, YOU GIVE A DEDUCTION TO
YOUR CHURCH, SO WHO'S MONEY
IS THAT?
IS THAT NOT THE GOVERNMENT'S
MONEY AND THEY CAN REGULATE THE
CHURCH BECAUSE IT'S A DEDUCTION.
00:02:53,373 --> 00:00:00,000
PEOPLE ARE ARGUING THIS.